a young wrestling phenom from kentucky
aliyah speck is just 10 years old but
southern living reports she just beat
out a boatload of older middle school
boys to earn second place at the state
finals hey alia look at
and you know she was given the choice to
wrestle against kids her own age or
level up and compete against boys that
were two to three years older and
aaliyah chose to go for the bigger
challenge and at the competition she
pinned her first opponent in 19 seconds
yes aaliyah
and next up aliyah is going to go hoping
to go to tulsa in november to compete
for an olympic rating and you can go to
our website for details on how you can
support her journey and i am inspired
drew you know what i want to do right
now huh i want to wrestle
i do i want to wrassle
would you hit it with me oh
one two three four i declare a thumb war
oh somewhere why don't we do arm
wrestling oh okay let's arm wrestle oh
that's hardcore okay ready settle up
there partner can you do this i don't
know i think my wrist is too dainty the
arm wrestle okay ready
one two three oh oh why are you so
strong you're freakishly
that's not fair come on man
that's not fun
[Applause]
really what's wrong with you
you guys i'm not kidding she's freaky
strong
you look all nice and then you roar and
you're not like you're you're like jimmy
fallon you don't let people win just to
be nice
at all did i really just beat you i
really did i need to work on my upper
body strength yeah i have to tell you
this story literally lifted me like i
was getting a facelift with puppet
strings i heard this story and i was
like this is the news you can use
stuff i'm so in love with alia i totally
want to support her journey she's so
cool
that is my
position when i'm waiting for postmates
the food delivery is that you that's
what i look like after i've
put my order in online and i'm waiting
for it to come to the door that's the
position i assume but
just
her story
really does it for me yeah i love her
i'm so excited only 10 years old to
watch out world for a leo did i really
beat you yeah you did
i'm not thrilled about that
i am you okay well this is a fun story
and really spoke to me people love true
crime like let's just get on with the
realities true crime rates for everybody
people are interested in it
um there's a lot of fans of it out there
and we have a job for you
insider reports magellan tv is looking
for a true crime fan who can watch crime
shows for 24 hours straight
this is not for the faint of heart you
have to watch shows like murder maps and
murder on the internet in a full day
marathon but crime watching pays a
hundred dollars per hour a total of
twenty four hundred dollars all you have
to do is document your crime watching
spree on social media ross could you do
it not at all no i watched two episodes
of forensic file once i didn't sleep for
a week it's not for me the scariest
thing i can handle is when julia roberts
cut her hair and steal magnolias
that is my line anything scary than that
i'm out it's so funny i thought you
would have been into this no true crime
no no
okay i don't like anything scary are you
kidding me i live like belle in beauty
and the beast just like
a cartoon bird lands on my shoulder
that's i don't want to happen well i
guess it depends 90 days fiance can be a
little scary
[Music]